hello everyone i wrote this article
recently for one of canada's major
newspapers the national post i'm reading
it for those of you who would rather
watch and listen
it's entitled
d-i-e
must die
this is why
i recently resigned from my position as
full tenured professor at the university
of toronto
i am now professor emeritus and before i
turn 60
emeritus is generally a designation
reserved for superannuated faculty
albeit those who had served their term
with some distinction
i had envisioned teaching and
researching at the u of t full time
until they had to haul my skeleton out
of my office
i loved my job
and my students undergraduates and
graduates alike were positively
predisposed toward me
but that career path was not meant to be
there are many reasons including the
fact that i can now teach many more
people and with less interference online
but here's a few more
first my qualified and supremely trained
heterosexual white male grad students
and i've had many others by the way are
no longer eligible upon graduation for
university research positions despite
stellar scientific dossiers
this is partly because of diversity
inclusivity and equity mandates
my preferred acronym
die
these have been imposed universally in
academia
despite the fact that university hiring
committees had already done everything
reasonable for all the years of my
career and then some to ensure that no
qualified minority candidates
were ever overlooked
my students are also partly unacceptable
precisely because they are my students
i am academic persona non-grata because
of my unacceptable philosophical
positions
and this isn't just some inconvenience
these facts rendered my job morally
untenable
how can i
accept
prospective researchers and train them
in good conscience knowing their
employment prospects to be minimal
second reason
this is one of many idiot issues of
appalling ideology currently demolishing
the universities and downstream the
general culture
not least because there are simply not
enough qualified bipark people in the
pipeline
by park black indigenous and people of
color for those of you not in the
knowing woke
this has been common knowledge among any
remotely truthful academic who has
served on a hiring committee for the
last three decades
this means we're out to produce a
generation of researchers utterly
unqualified
for the job
and we've seen what that means already
in the horrible grievance studies
disciplines
that combined with the death of
objective testing
has compromised the university so badly
that it can hardly be overstated
and what happens in the universities
eventually colors everything
as we have discovered
all my craven colleagues
must craft die statements
to obtain a research grant
they all
lie
accepting the minority of true believers
and they teach their students to do the
same
and they do it constantly with various
rationalizations and justifications
further corrupting what is already a
stunningly corrupt enterprise
some of my colleagues even allow
themselves to undergo so-called
anti-bias training conducted by
supremely unqualified human resources
personnel
lecturing inanely and blithely and in an
accusatory manner about theoretically
all pervasive racist sexist heterosexist
attitudes
such training is now often a
precondition to occupy a faculty
position on a hiring committee
need i point out
that implicit attitudes cannot by the
definitions generated by those who have
made them a central point of our culture
be transformed by short-term explicit
training
assuming that those biases exist in the
manner claimed and that is a very weak
claim and i'm speaking scientifically
here the implicit association test the
much vaunted iat which purports to
objectively diagnose implicit bias
that's automatic racism and the like is
by no means powerful enough valid and
reliable enough to do
what it purports to do
two of the original designers of that
test anthony greenwald and brian nozick
have said as much
publicly the third
professor mazarine banerjee of harvard
remains recalcitrant much of this can be
attributed to her overtly leftist
political agenda as well as to her
embeddedness within a subdiscipline of
psychology social psychology
so corrupt that it denied the existence
of left-wing authoritarianism for six
decades after world war ii
the same social psychologists broadly
speaking also casually regard
conservatism in the guise of system
justification
as a form of psychopathology
banaji's continued countenancing of the
misuse of her research instrument
combined with the status of her position
at harvard is a prime reason we all
still suffer under the dye yoke with its
baleful effect on what was once the
closest we had ever come to truly
meritorious selection
furthermore the accrediting board for
grad clinical psych training programs in
canada are now planning to refuse to
accredit university clinical programs
unless they have a social justice
orientation
that combined with some recent
legislative changes in canada claiming
to outlaw so-called conversion therapy
but really making it exceedingly risky
for clinicians to do anything ever but
agree always and about everything with
their clients have likely doomed the
practice of clinical psychology which
always depended entirely on trust and
privacy
similar moves are afoot in other
professional disciplines
such as medicine and law
and if you don't think that
psychologists lawyers and other
professionals are anything but terrified
of their now woke governing professional
colleges much to everyone's extreme
detriment you simply don't understand
how far all of this has gone
just exactly what am i supposed to do
when i meet a grad student or young
professor hired on die grounds manifest
instant skepticism regarding their
professional ability
what a slap in the face to a truly
meritorious outsider
and perhaps that's the point
the die ideology is not friend to peace
and tolerance
it is absolutely and completely the
enemy of competence
and justice
and for those of you who think that i am
overstating the case or that this is
something limited in some trivial sense
to the university consider some other
examples
this report from hollywood cliched
hotbed of liberal sentiment for example
indicates just how far this is gone
in 2020 the academy of motion picture
arts and sciences the oscar people
embarked on a five-year plan
does that ring any historical bells
to quote diversify our organization
and expand our definition of the best
they did so in an attempt which included
developing quote new representation and
inclusion standards for oscars
two hypothetically quote better reflect
the diversity of the movie-going
audience
what fruit has this initiative offspring
of the dye ideology born
according to a recent article penned by
peter kieffer and peter savadnik but
posted on former new york times
journalist barry weiss's common sense
website
and weiss left the times because of the
intrusion of radical left ideology into
that newspaper just as terra henley did
recently vis-a-vis the cbc
quote
we spoke to more than 25 writers
directors and producers all of whom
identify as liberal
and all of whom described a pervasive
fear of running a foul of the new dogma
how to survive the revolution
by becoming its most ardent supporter
suddenly every conversation with every
agent or head of content started with is
anyone bipark attached to
this and this is everywhere
and if you don't see it your head is
either in the sand or shoved somewhere
far more unmentionable
cbs for example has literally mandated
that every writer's room be at least 40
percent bypoc in 2021
in 2022.
we are now at the point where race
ethnicity gender or sexual preference is
first accepted as the fundamental
characteristic defining each person just
as the radical leftists were hoping and
second is now treated as the most
important qualification for study
research
and employment
need i point out that this is insane
even the benighted new york times has
its doubts
a headline from august 11 2021
are workplace diversity programs doing
more harm than good
in a word
yes
how can accusing your employees of
racism etc
sufficient to require retraining
particularly in relationship to those
who are working in good faith to
overcome whatever bias they might still
in these modern liberal times manifest
be anything other than insulting
annoying invasive high-handed moralizing
inappropriate ill-considered
counterproductive
and otherwise unjustifiable
and if you think die is bad
and it is
wait until you get a load of
environmental social and governance
esg scores
see the vanguard website for more
information
purporting to assess corporate moral
responsibility these scores which can
dramatically affect an enterprise's
financial viability
are nothing less than the equivalent of
china's damnable social credit system
applied to the entrepreneurial and
financial world
ceos
what in the world
is wrong with you
can't you see that the ideologues who
push such appalling nonsense are driven
by an agenda that is not only absolutely
antithetical to your free market
enterprise as such but precisely
targeted at the freedoms that made your
success possible
can't you see
that by going along sheep-like just as
the professors are doing just as the
artists and writers are doing that you
are generating a veritable fifth column
within your businesses
are you really so blind cowed and
cowardly with all your so-called
privilege
and it's not just the universities and
the professional colleges and hollywood
and the corporate world
diversity inclusivity and equity that
radical leftist trinity is destroying us
wondering about the divisiveness that is
currently besetting us look no farther
than die
wondering more specifically about the
attractiveness of trump
look no further than die
when does the left
go too far
when they worship at the altar of die
and insist that the rest of us who
mostly want to be left alone
do so as well
enough already enough enough
finally
do you know that vladimir putin himself
is capitalizing on this woke madness
anna majar barducci at memri.org
covered his recent speech
i quote from the article's translation
putin speaking the advocates of
so-called social progress believe they
are introducing humanity to some kind of
a new and better consciousness
godspeed hoist the flags as we say go
right ahead
the only thing that i want to say now is
that their prescriptions are not new at
all
it may come as a surprise to some people
but russia
has been there already
after the 1917 revolution the bolsheviks
relying on the dogmas of marx and
ingalls also said that they would change
existing ways and customs and not just
political and economic ones but the very
notion of human morality and the
foundations of a healthy society
the destruction of age-old values
religion and relations between people up
to and including the total rejection of
family we had that too
encouragement to inform on loved ones
all this was proclaimed progress and by
the way was widely supported around the
world back then and was quite
fashionable
same as today
by the way the bolsheviks were
absolutely intolerant of opinions other
than theirs
putin continues
this i believe should call to mind some
of what we are witnessing now
looking at what is happening in a number
of western countries we are amazed to
see domestic practices which we
fortunately have left i hope in the
distant past
the fight for equality and against
discrimination has turned into
aggressive dogmatism bordering on
absurdity when the works of the great
authors of the past such as shakespeare
are no longer taught at schools or
universities because their ideas are
believed to be backward
the classics are declared backward and
ignorant of the importance of gender and
race
in hollywood memos are distributed about
proper storytelling and how many
characters of what color or gender
should be in a movie
this
is even worse than the agit prop
department of the central committee of
the communist party of the soviet union
end of putin's comments
this from the head of the former
totalitarian enterprise against whom we
fought a five decades-long cold war
risking the entire planet in a very real
manner this from the head of a country
riven in a literally genocidal manner by
ideas that putin himself attributes to
the progressives in the west to the
generally accepting audience of his once
burned
once
twice shy listeners
and all of you going along with the die
activists whatever your reasons
this is on you
professors cowering cravenly in pretense
and silence teaching your students to
dissimulate and lie to get along as the
walls crumble
for shame
ceos signaling a virtue you don't
possess and shouldn't want to to please
a minority who literally live by
displeasure
your evil capitalists after all should
be proud of it
at the moment i can't tell if you're
more reprehensibly timid even than the
professors why the hell don't you banish
the human resource die upstarts back to
the more appropriately named personnel
departments stop them from interfering
with the psyches of you and your
employees and be done with it
musicians artists writers stop bending
your sacred and meritorious art to the
demands of the propagandists before you
fatally betray the spirit of your own
intuition
stop censoring your thought
stop saying you will hire for your
orchestral and theatrical productions
for any reason other than talent and
excellence
that's all you have
that's all any of us have
he who sows the wind will reap the
whirlwind
and the wind is rising